well adam we know that emergency
services from devon and cornwall police
are attending to a scene in helston in
cornwall where they are responding to
what they say
is a plane crash military sources are
confirming to us that this aircraft is a
royal navy hawk
t1 jet we know that halston is home to
rns called rose this is the home of the
royal navy's fleet
of aircraft based in the very
southwestern part of
england we know that this base is the
largest helicopter base in europe it's
got some 3 000
personnel working there as for what we
know of this particular aircraft where
we know it was part of the 736
naval squadron their primary role is to
provide
stimulated missile attacks um to
enemy uh sources we know that this
squadron though is also responsible for
flying missions for students
at the royal navy school of fighter
control we understand that both crew
members were rejected
and those military sources telling us
that there are no fatalities but devon
and cornwall police
urging the public to stay away from the
area